sure you ready for this  that's  sorry I I got kidnapped by twins once  nearly they killed my boyfriend Hector  sometimes it just takes the tragedy  find your own lasagna yeah who's your  enemy yeah we try other chokehold yeah  yeah we show you this okay okay what you  want to do here is change your leverage  position okay so give an elbow to the  midsection oh good shot to the groin you  know you can be a victim or you can  totally get to the bottom of it you know  good good  so I've been doing all this internet  research and I've discovered that diet  Hector and the twins they're all  connected oh damn girl the hell are you  even doing got you so strong  I'm training like I'm on a mission we do  it again you want to do it yeah hell  yeah all right it'll be ready for them  this time what's up okay